tu as l'impression Charlie que personne
ne peut te comprendre
parce qu'on parle de tes parents mais
que
Charlie Garcia je m'appelle Sébastien
on est tous les deux en 4e d HP ou
potentiel c'est une classe pour les
enfants précoces et on s'est rencontrés
parce que on avait tous les deux les
mêmes sujets d'intérêt et
on est devenu habillé bah moi je l'ai
trouvé c'était le jour de la rentrée
ça il était je le sentais stressé
et
donc à la récréation je suis allée
parler puis depuis on est devenu
tu étais stressé n'arrivée dans cette
école oui oui parce que quand on a passé
deux ans dans les écoles où c'était
infernal alors forcément
j'étais pas sûr de ce qui allait arriver
cette année là mais je suis allé tout de
suite voir Sébastien parce que j'en ai
entendu j'en avais entendu parler et je
me suis dit tiens je vais enfin
rencontré un garçon vraiment vraiment
intelligent
Sébastien on m'avait dit il y a un élève
dans la classe qui a qui a 9 ans et qui
est en 4e il a sauté trois classes je
crois bien non 4 4 et
il a un cuit très très élevé
Sébastien toi tu t'es toujours ressenti
comme les autres ou différents des
autres plutôt comme les autres ça c'est
toujours très bien passé sauf le premier
jour la rentrée du CO2 à l'époque
j'avais 5 ans
petit la maternelle c'est là-bas ah non
c'est là-bas la maternelle je te dis
mais ils insistait ils insistaient il y
en a un qui m'a compris un
et le 1 le Rex a expliqué tout seul tout
seul à quel moment tu as commencé toi à
tu t'en souviens à sauter des classes
comment ça s'est passé pour toi ouais
j'ai commencé j'ai fait la maternelle
enfin première année maternelle
c'était normal puis après on m'a fait
sauter une classe donc je suis arrivé
directement dernière section de
maternelle et puis on m'a dit c'était le
matin
dernière section de maternelle
l'après-midi bon
votre enfant il peut pas rester en
CP on va le mettre au CE1
le matin toujours dernière section de
maternelle l'après-midi
j'arrive à la fin de l'année on déménage
CE2 CM1 CM2 normal et après je rentre
que
et j'ai fait 6ème cinquième et cette
année 4e mais sixième cinquième c'est en
combien d'années
est-ce que toi tu te ressens en décalage
par rapport aux autres puisque tu es
plus jeune plus petit que les autres bah
les autres prennent ma petite taille
comme
quelque chose pour profiter de me taper
etc ah bon il y a des fois
il y avait des fois au début de l'année
on me tapait de la classe me tapait mais
sans se rendre compte croyait que
c'était de la plaisanterie
alors tu disais toi que tu étais arrivé
ici avec des difficultés dans les autres
écoles ça se passait comment ailleurs
Charlie pour toi
en primaire ça allait relativement bien
mais si en arrivant en 6e que les
problèmes ont commencé
je me suis fait insulter et beaucoup
d'autres choses qui vont avec au départ
je pensais que c'était à cause des
cheveux longs que j'avais à l'époque
et en arrivant en cinquième on va couper
les cheveux comme j'avais les cheveux
les cheveux coupés je me suis dit je
vais enfin pouvoir partager mes
connaissances sans me sans recevoir un
marron dans la figure et je me suis
trompé en fait j'ai partagé mes
connaissances et puis une semaine
peut-être deux jours après la situation
c'est complètement renversée je me
faisais poursuivre dans la cour de
l'école
insulter également
lapidé aussi à coup de Pierre parfois et
puis des coups de pied
tu as reçu des pierres
pensaient que c'était la nature humaine
que c'était parce que j'étais précoce et
tout ça qui t'avait dit que tu étais
précoce à ce moment-là je devais avoir 7
ans et on a fait des tests de cuir
et
on m'a expliqué que j'avais 135 de QI
mais que j'aurais dû avoir beaucoup plus
c'est parce que je suis très lent au
test j'aurais dû avoir plus mais j'ai eu
ce tuile là ce qui était déjà pas mal et
on te l'a dit c'est marqué le fait quand
le dise non mais mes parents qui ont
aussi exagéré un petit peu
j'ai peut-être à fier sinon
beaucoup parlé c'est ça que tu veux dire
oui je pense
ça m'a pas spécialement marqué parce que
à l'époque j'avais pas encore de
problème mais c'est arrivé
c'est arrivé en 5e que j'ai vraiment
j'étais dégoûté de l'espèce humaine à
vie d'ailleurs
à ce point oui c'est vrai oui oui faut
aller entendre ce que je disais à
l'époque mais aussi il faut comprendre
que j'étais persécuté c'était pas
agréable à vivre
et forcément
tu t'es retrouvé
j'avais deux choix psychologiques soit
c'est moi qui suis stupide soit le monde
entier alors forcément mais alors tu as
choisi quoi comme version à votre avis
le reste du monde entier était stupide
plus maintenant en tout cas qu'est-ce
qu'il y a pour toi comme différence
entre le moment où tu étais toi à
l'école primaire et maintenant où tu es
au collège ici dans donc dans une école
que l'on dit et dans une classe que l'on
dit à eau potentiel c'est ça HP
c'est
le moins d'ennuis quand même
parce que en primaire c'était bon allez
les enfants on va faire la leçon on
lisait la leçon la faisait le lendemain
allez on continue la leçon on
réapprenait la même chose
le surlendemain
allez on va continuer la leçon même
chose moi pour les deux derniers cours
c'était
tu t'ennuyais voilà et puis après bon ça
n'allait pas assez vite
ce que tu as des passions des hobbies la
Grèce antique
le football et les origines de l'homme
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de faire plus
tard
[Musique]
un petit métier
qu'on fait sans études quoi parce que je
peux quand même mettre mes capacités
en œuvre
Charlie qu'est-ce que tu veux faire toi
est-ce que tu as déjà une idée sur le
métier que tu aimerais exercer non pas
tellement je voudrais faire un métier
qui qui soit en rapport avec mes
passions
peut-être
un paléontologue
peut-être un dessinateur aussi ou en
écrivain
mais j'aime bien écrire oui
j'ai l'année dernière j'écrivais des
nouvelles
fantastiques pour faire peur en fait
comme j'étais persécuté ma façon à moi
de me défouler c'est pas de les foulées
sur un d'être vivant ou ben
je mets ma toute ma douleur
sur papier seulement je dessine ou
j'écris et tes PARENTS tu parlais
beaucoup avec eux ils étaient à l'écoute
de tout ça
un objet inanimé ça ça comprend beaucoup
plus que que mes parents en tout cas un
objet inanimé qu'est-ce que c'est un
objet inanimé une peluche
par exemple mais pas seulement
n'importe quoi
comprends mieux que quiconque
suffit de dessiner un visage bout de
papier et de lui parler jamais il ira
répété ce qu'il entend ce que j'ai
entendu enfin
s'il a entendu j'ai l'impression Charlie
que personne ne peut te comprendre
parce qu'on parle de tes parents
quelqu'un dans le même cas que moi peut
me comprendre mais pas de mes parents je
pense
que tu es suivi toi par un psychologue
oui oui j'étais
je suis encore actuellement suivi par un
psychologue
mais je pense que c'est plus très très
utile actuellement
peut-être parce que je vais beaucoup
mieux maintenant
ici je suis au milieu de gens qui me
ressemble est-ce que tu aimes bien toi
le monde dans lequel tu vis moi je
trouve que le monde dans lequel nous
vivons est complètement absurde notre
intelligence on la gâche complètement on
a un immense cerveau qui prend toute
notre boîte crânienne et on la
transforme en crime en crime en guerre
alors certes les lions sont cannibales
parfois
les fourmis font des guerres aussi mais
nous on a tout à la fois quoi le genre
humain tu détestes les animaux sont plus
sympas il y a des qualités chez les
animaux
c'est tellement rare
des petites copines
vous en avez non non j'ai l'impression
d'être asexué comme les comme les
ouvrières fourmis
c'est vrai
ça me barbe d'ailleurs tous les gens qui
s'embrassent aussi cinéma il y a la
moitié du temps qui est pas quoi c'est
pénible c'est vraiment pénible surtout
que l'amour humain c'est un croisement
entre celui de l'éphémère et le la
punaise l'éphémère
l'éphémère sa vie ne sert qu'à ça en
fait il vit une seule journée et c'est
pour sa couplé et la punaise elle fait
avec n'importe qui n'importe quand
n'importe où n'importe comment n'importe
quoi
tu ne te dis pas que tu vas être à jour
amoureux tu n'as pas envie d'être
amoureux d'aimer non tu n'as pas envie
non tu veux rester tout seul toi si tout
le monde faisait comme moi il y aura
déjà moins d'êtres humains il y aura
moins de famine si on gérait nos petits
comme le font les reines fourmis il y
aurait pas ses problèmes de famille ni
de guerre la guerre et la famine c'est à
cause du manque de
un milliard de 1 milliard de Chinois ça
devrait être le nombre d'humains sur
terre
sont terribles ils ne s'aiment pas c'est
violent et tu n'aimes pas non plus
l'amour alors tu voudrais qu'il soit
comment ce monde dans quelques minutes à
quoi ça sert de alors c'est normal de
s'accoupler pour faire des petits mais
si on met dans le préservatif on fait
l'amour pourquoi en fait si on fait même
pas de petits à ce moment-là ça n'a plus
aucun sens c'est c'est sans que ni tête
si j'appuie hier
c'est toi tu ne le vois le justement tu
te parles de l'acte sexuel que pour se
reproduire mais l'amour dans tout ça
l'amour dans tout ça c'est juste un acte
de reproduction qui a monté en graine
voilà en plus on a mis un tabou sur
l'amour et ça le rend encore plus
puissant en fait mais s'il tabou ça
avait été de manger il y aura
actuellement au lieu des films X des
films de manger où on voit les gens en
train de manger
ce serait ce serait d'ailleurs assez
amusant et puis il peut en dire ah non
tu regardes pas ce film c'est interdit
au moins de 16 ans on voit les gens
manger c'est ce serait ce sera mieux
est-ce que vous vous sentez-vous des
enfants vous sentez déjà des adultes
ni l'un ni l'autre entre les deux plutôt
je me sens entre les deux moi je sais
pas très bien ce que la sensation d'être
un enfant ou un adulte
à mon avis si jamais
si je connais ça la différence je
pourrais le dire mais là non je vois pas
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]